- [Kim] How do you define freedom?
Stop for a minute and picture
what it means to be free.
What comes into your mind?
Traveling wherever you please,
having enough money to do what you want,
or is freedom better
defined by what it's not?
Not having anyone telling you what to do,
not being in prison?
Freedom is a core aspect
of US national identity,
but if someone gave you box
labeled Contents: Freedom,
what would you expect to find inside?
This was the question that
the United States faced
during Reconstruction, the
period following the Civil War,
when the US government,
Southern state governments,
and African Americans
attempted to negotiate
a new social and political
order for the South.
But what African Americans
expected to find in the box
labeled Freedom was very different
from what their former
enslavers wanted to put there.
Was freedom just the absence of slavery,
as most white Southerners believed,
or did it imply citizenship,
political power,
and economic self-sufficiency?
Try to solve this dilemma,
Congress passed, and the states ratified,
three new Constitutional amendments
during the Reconstruction
era, the 13th Amendment,
which ended the system of slavery in 1865,
the 14th Amendment, which
extended citizenship
to all persons born or
naturalized in the United States
in 1868, and the 15th Amendment,
which gave black men the
right to vote in 1870.
So in just five years,
African Americans in the South
went from personal property
to full civic participants,
at least in theory.
In reality, how different were definitions
of freedom, citizenship, and democracy
before and after Reconstruction?
To really answer this question,
we need to examine continuity and change
in the Reconstruction era.
What stayed the same and what changed
in each of these three areas
following the passage of the
Reconstruction Amendments?
Okay, first let's look at
continuities and changes
in the definition of freedom.
Before the end of slavery,
African Americans had neither
economic nor physical freedom.
They didn't have control of their bodies
or of their labor.
The pass system kept
them from moving freely,
and slavery itself meant
that they couldn't choose
where to work or earn
money from their own work.
So how much did their
physical and economic freedom
change after the 13th
Amendment outlawed slavery?
Well, their economic self-sufficiency
went through some ups and downs.
Most African Americans believed
that their years of
unpaid toil entitled them
to land of their own.
US Army general William Tecumseh Sherman
redistributed Confederate territory
on the coasts of Georgia
and South Carolina
to black families, who
farmed there for a few years
until Lincoln's successor, Andrew Johnson,
gave all confiscated land
back to its former owners.
Instead, most black farmers
became sharecroppers,
renting a portion of a
white landowner's farm
in exchange for part of the crop yield.
This gave black farmers a lot more freedom
over their own work,
since they didn't have to
work under an overseer.
But economically, sharecropping
kept black farmers,
as well as small white farmers,
in an endless cycle of debt and poverty.
After the 13th Amendment, most
Southern state governments
attempted to limit the physical freedom
of African Americans as well,
with statutes known as the Black Codes.
Many of these codes defined anyone
who wasn't under a labor
contract as a vagrant
who could be arrested and
have their labor sold.
Later, segregation limited
the physical freedom
of where Southern African
Americans could go
and what they could do.
Laws like the Black Codes,
which so obviously attempted
to institute slavery
by another name, led Congress
to pass the 14th Amendment,
which defined a US citizen
as anyone born or naturalized
in the United States
and specifically prevented states
from infringing upon
the rights of citizens.
Before the Civil War,
citizenship was exclusively
the privilege of white Americans.
Non-white immigrants weren't
eligible to become US citizens,
and the 1857 Supreme Court
decision in Dred Scott
declared that no African Americans
could be citizens at all.
The 14th Amendment, ratified in 1868,
led to a huge increase in
the number of US citizens
and it decoupled
citizenship from whiteness.
Even the American-born
children of Asian immigrants
were citizens.
But the Supreme Court
defined the 14th Amendment
very narrowly in the late 19th
century, permitting many laws
that discriminated on the basis of race.
Only in the 20th century
would the 14th Amendment
become an important tool
for civil rights activists
to break down segregation.
Lastly, the 15th Amendment,
ratified in 1870,
extended the right to vote to black men.
In the years leading up to the Civil War,
with few exceptions, only white
man had the right to vote.
The 15th Amendment radically
redefined the terms
of American democracy.
During Reconstruction, more
than 2,000 African Americans
held public office,
including two US senators.
But there were limits
to this new broader
definition of democracy.
First, it didn't include women,
much to the frustration of
the women's suffrage movement.
Then, as the federal
government ceased to intervene
to protect black citizens in
the South in the late 1870s,
Southern state governments imposed a range
of voter suppression tactics
to effectively bar African
Americans from voting,
which then reduced the likelihood
of black politicians winning office.
Not until the 1960s
would African American voter registration
once again reach
Reconstruction-era levels.
So how much did the
Reconstruction Amendments
change definitions of freedom,
citizenship, and democracy?
Well, after the amendments,
African Americans were free
to own their own bodies
and labor, but that was about it.
The 14th and 15th Amendments
led to short-lived revolutions
in the concept of citizenship
and in voting rights,
but those rights had all but evaporated
by the end of the century.
Nevertheless, although they
didn't have much of an impact
in the short term, these
amendments would lay the foundation
for the civil rights movement
of the 1950s and '60s.